now there's a few different ways you can
approach this
and they're all valid probably assuming
you follow the same rules that we've
been working on so far
and the first thing i see and i'm not
the only one
the first thing i see is this the angle
is very large this angle is very large
right i can work with this much easier
if it's a smaller angle
okay now sine sine is periodic every how
many degrees
360. every 360 degrees is the same thing
it's the same thing so i could add 360
degrees to this it'll be the same
i could take away 360 degrees and it
would be the same and you can see
because this is a big positive number
i probably want to subtract do you agree
with that
so you don't have to put this line in
but just in case you're not quite
following
i'm going to take that and i'm going to
say that's equal
to this i've shifted 360 degrees
horizontally
okay and i'm still the same now of
course
270 minus 360 will be minus 9.
okay so far so good
yeah which
from line one to line two online two to
line three
okay you need to go back and have a look
at our work on periodic functions
okay that it repeats
because there's a big angle right and
you'll have to do this eventually anyhow
so that this number would be smaller
because this number is enormous i have
no idea how far 270 degrees goes
to make it easier to work with
okay you're 11. are you ready to pick up
again yes
yep okay good so now
i note that what's happening here this
minus sign right
i'll just put it around the right order
what's happening here is it looks like
there are two minus signs but there are
really there's really only one
right really only one so if i factorize
that out
it'll be minus x plus 90.
right so now we can see what direction
this is really going in
okay now just before i do that because
sine is an odd function sine of minus
something right we minus sine of the
same thing
right so for example sine of minus 30
degrees
is the same as minus sine 30 they're
both
minus a half okay so i'm going to apply
that logic here
for odd functions that minus sign can
creep out the front
right because it's an odd function not
because you know
it's algebra it's because it's a
particular kind of function
with symmetry so i'm going to write it
out the front
you're happy with that see what i've
done because it's an odd function
in fact you may even like to put over
here as
sine x is an odd
function right that's the reason why
okay all right i'm almost there sine
x was 90. we looked at this like 10
minutes ago right what is this thing
it's close it's closed so now to
convince yourself because you know what
this looks like
let's chuck this in sign 270
minus x bam
that looks like minus cause to me
now i'll admit there's a lot of lines
there but maybe half those lines you
don't need to write i'm just writing in
there to make it really
obvious to you what's going on